so you're looking to start your first
online business but you're not sure
where to start you've come to the right
place play the intro what's going on
guys
my name is Devin Tallmadge and welcome
back to the channel today we're going to
be talking about how you can find and
procure your first product to start an
online business we're going to be
talking about three things in particular
one where to find your first product -
how to get your first sample than three
how're you gonna turn that sample into
your first physical product ready to
launch the market the first question
most people ask me is where did you
start where did you find your first
product and how did you get your samples
well truth be told I found my first
product online on the website called
Alabama it's basically like a Chinese
version of eBay you can find pretty much
anything for very low costs but when I
tell you that I searched everywhere but
and found my first product there that
doesn't mean that's where I stopped
Alibaba is a great resource for you to
search and find your first product and
you're gonna find some great
manufacturers there but chances are
you're gonna find the lower end of the
manufacturers they're the ones that are
looking to get the most amount of volume
the false mouth price now if you're
looking to pump out millions of units of
t-shirts or something like that yes you
might find a good manufacturer in other
Baba but from my personal experience I
think there's a better way to go around
it so when you've hit the Alibaba
homepage you're going to find that it's
a pretty simple layout it's very similar
to other programs like eBay and Amazon
that you can literally type in what
you're looking for and it's going to
throw out a whole list of different
suppliers from here you're going to want
to select about 10 to 20 different
suppliers that maybe you want to work
with in the future I know this sounds
like a lot but chances are half of those
people aren't gonna reply to you and the
other half well you might get a
half-decent reply when you send that
first email to supply up make sure you
try and establish a good rapport good
rapport is very important because these
people are looking to start a good
business relationship with you just as
much as you are looking to do with them
so in your first email make sure you
include your name wait from and roughly
what you're looking to build
they know a lot more about your business
than you do already and they know what
they can achieve and what they can't if
you tell them that you're looking to do
something way out of the ordinary
chances are they might be able to help
you but there's also a chance they might
not be able to and they will be honest
with you so tell them what you're
looking to do and don't have any
reservations here anybody that tells
them that they want to sign a
nondisclosure agreement or anything like
that straight off the bat they're not
gonna reply to you they're not even
going to be interested so take your time
to try and establish some good rapport
here so this is where it gets a little
bit tricky and experience matters when
you send out a bunch of emails on
Alibaba in regards to a particular
product Alibaba is also going to tell
lots of other suppliers that you've done
so and then they're going to come and
contact you first you haven't talked to
these people you haven't checked out
their resumes and you haven't checked
out their company chances are they're
not that great so make sure you filter
all the emails that come back to you and
make sure you double-check if you've
sent them an email first so this is
where it's that talking samples to the
suppliers and really push the Alibaba
experience as far as they can once
you've been talking to supplier for a
while and establish good rapport they're
going to start trying to convince you to
buy some samples of me and yes at the
beginning you're definitely going to
have to buy some samples nobody's going
to give you free stuff just because
you're looking to start a company and if
they are it's very rare that they're
going to do so when your first sample
arrives this is where you're going to
understand what I'm talking about the
Alibaba experience and the quality of
suppliers on the platform chances are
the supply you've selected doesn't speak
the best English and there's been some
miscommunication in between what you
told them on what they've actually
produced but this is okay this sample
that you've paid for is now a big
investment into the future of your
company what you need to do here is
contact the supplier again and let them
know that there's been an issue tell
them that something's gone wrong and try
and explain what has gone wrong to them
if they're a decent company they're
going to tell you that it's okay and
they're going to try and fix the problem
don't worry about it they'll pay for all
shipping and they'll pay for everything
and they're going to make sure they give
you the best product possible now my
experience this wasn't the case for
those of you don't know I started a
company called wire watches I'll pop a
link in the description for you if you
want to check it out but basically for
me
they sent out a sample that was full of
dust it was full of little particles
behind the glass and I wasn't satisfied
with the quality I sent an email to my
supplier basically asking them for
another strap supplier saying that what
they produced wasn't exactly what I was
looking for and could they help me find
somebody else that we could combined our
forces with and hopefully create one
great product
this was my stepping stone into another
supplier and into another world away
from Alibaba thankfully the company I
was working with at the time was more
than happy to accommodate any of my
concerns and questions so they sent me a
few different emails and I started
chatting to different suppliers outside
of the other bubble platform from here
on in I continued using the same method
to find the suppliers I'm with today now
it took me 11 months to bring my first
watch to market this may seem like a lot
of time and a crazy amount of time to
spend on samples and procurement but I
wasn't willing to spend almost my life
savings at that point in time to start a
company with another company that I had
no trust in this is my only
recommendation to you it took me 11
months to bring my first product to
market this is because it took me a long
time to find a company that spoke good
English and that I could trust this is
the one piece of advice that'll offer to
anybody starting in the econ game in
2019 make sure the company speaks very
good English and make sure you trust
chances are up they've developed five or
six different samples for the same
company you're going to learn to trust
these people and they're going to learn
to trust you once you're happy with the
final sample everything's perfect you're
into place you've first order for your
very first product congratulations
you've just started your first company
from the comfort of your own home if you
have any questions make sure you drop a
comment below and I'll get back to you
as soon as I can
otherwise if you like this video smash
that subscribe button
20-19 style and I'll see you in the next
one